[Applaus]
[Musik]
was wenn ich euch sagen würde dass die
Gaskrise und der Krieg in der Ukraine
eine einzigartige Chance für ein
bestimmtes Land darstellen könnten von
welchem Land die Rede ist den USA Katar
weit gefehlt heute geht es um Spanien
überrascht ja Spanien könnte tatsächlich
der größte erdgaslieferant in Europa
werden oder besitzt zumindest ihre viel
Potenzial ein großer Verteiler der
Ressource zu werden wenn es keine
katastrophalen Fehler begeht und ich bin
nicht der einzige der so denkt schaut
euch an
Spanien könnte Russland ablösen und so
wichtigsten erdgast Drehscheibe der EU
werden ich weiß was er jetzt denkt vor
allem wenn ihr langjährige Zuschauer von
visualpolitik seid vielleicht ist dies
das erste Video überhaupt in diese
tatsächlich positiv über Spanien
sprechen denn es scheint das immer wenn
in der Welt irgendetwas schief läuft
Spanien ist irgendwie fertig bringt noch
einen drauf zu setzen aber zum ersten
Mal befinden wir uns in Europa in einer
Wirtschaftskrise in der die Deutschen
wirklich in Schwierigkeiten sind und die
Südeuropäer die Lösung sein könnten
warum weil Spanien im Gegensatz zu
Deutschland immer nur sehr wenig Gas aus
Russland gekauft hat
[Musik]
jahrzehntelang war Algerien Spaniens
wichtigster Gaslieferant ja es stimmt
algerien ist ein weiteres dieser Länder
in den Menschenrechte gerne mal
übersehen werden aber es ist nicht
Russland und es hat Gas und nicht nur
das Spanien ist das Land das am besten
auf die Aufnahme von Flüssigkeit aus den
Vereinigten Staaten oder vorbereitet ist
um euch einen Eindruck zu verschaffen
27% der Regel zertifizierungskapazität
ganz Europa befinden sich auf spanischem
Boden was erregertifizierung ist nun das
ist das rückumwandeln von Flüssigkeit
Energie in Gas in seine gasförmigen Form
mit anderen Worten es würde reichen eine
Gaspipeline zu bauen die Spanien mit
Frankreich und den Rest Europas
verbindet und Madrid und über Nacht zum
Epizentrum des Gasmarkt in Europa werden
klingt fantastisch nicht wahr nun ja das
wäre der Fall wenn in Spanien die Logik
regieren würde aber die Realität sieht
leider ganz anders aus Russland ist
Spanien jetzt zweitgrößte Gaslieferant
da die algerischen gasflüsse sinken okay
seien wir ehrlich diese Nachricht ist
ein klein direkt für die Dramaturgie
dieses Videos sie stellt keine Fake News
da aber man könnte sagen dass sie eine
Halbwahrheit ist in diesem Fall sind die
bloomwork Leute ein bisschen den
clickbait verfallen inwiefern das werden
wir euch noch erklären sicher ist jedoch
das Spanien in einer Zeit in der sehr
große Retter Europas sein könnte eine
Reihe von katastrophalen Entscheidungen
getroffen hat Entscheidungen die dazu
führten dass zumindest vorübergehend
mehr russisches Gas gekauft wurde als
vor dem Krieg und ihr fragt euch
vielleicht was soll das Ganze nun die
Antwort liegt in einem Wort Marokko und
was hat Marokko mit all den zu tun am
Ende des Videos werdet ihr es genau
verstehen
[Musik]
ich warne euch jedoch im Voraus bei
diesem Thema kann man den Glauben an
Logik und rationale Entscheidungen in
der Politik leicht verliert also nur für
den Fall falls ihr da noch irgendwelche
Illusionen hattet die Frage die wir uns
heute stellen lautet also warum kauft
Spanien russisches Gas warum will
Algerien nicht mit dem Verkauf von Gas
an ganz Europa über Spanien ein Vermögen
machen könnte Spanien wirklich eine
Drehscheibe werden um russisches Gas zu
ersetzen heute werden wir all diese
Fragen beantworten und zwar gleich nach
einem kleinen Hinweis unseres Sponsors
nordpass nordpass ist ein Tool mit dem
ihr eure Passwörter sicher aufbewahren
könnt egal ob es um Website Anwendungen
oder Kreditkarten geht mit nordpass
kannst du automatisch sichere Passwörter
für jedes deine Konten erstellen und sie
eine Haut speichern ohne dass sie sie
bemerken musst dadurch vermeidest du
auch die Unsitte ein Passwort mehrfach
zu benutzen denn wenn dieses dann
irgendwo geknackt oder geliebt wird
verliert man auf den Überblick was
dadurch alles gefährdet sein könnte und
deswegen geht noch einen Schritt weiter
und schützt deine Daten nicht nur passiv
sondern auch proaktiven im ganzen
Arsenal von Security Features dort passt
premiums kennt zum Beispiel das Internet
kontinuierlich nach deinen Daten ab und
findet heraus ob diese nicht
möglicherweise gelegt wurden und falls
dies der Fall sein sollte Wand ist nicht
so dass Du rechtzeitig reagieren und die
Gefahr bannen kannst bevor schlimmeres
Unglück hereinbricht darüber hinaus sind
die in nordpass abgelegten Passwort und
Kreditkarten auf all deinen Endgeräten
verfügbar ganz einfach per Auto für so
dass du nicht nur sicherer fährst
sondern auch noch viel Zeit Spaß und das
Beste für die visualpolitik und die hat
noch fast eine ganz besondere Aktion bei
Abschluss eines 2 Jahresabos bekommst du
einen Monat kostenlos dazu wenn du den
Link passt und kommst gleich wieso
alpolitik aufrufst den du in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video findest
natürlich kannst du alles in Ruhe und
verbindlich und völlig ohne Risiko
ausprobieren denn nordpass kommt mit
einer 30-tägigen Geld zurück Garantie
als sie sich bis dahin nicht von seinen
Vorzügen überzeugen sollte also nicht
viel los besorgt euch nordpass und
greift damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnte
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links in ihrem ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung bei denn damit
hätte uns auch vielleicht noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun zurück zu unseren brennenden Fragen
welche wir wie so oft zuerst mit einem
kurzen Blick in die Geschichte
beantworten wollen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Marokko der unbequeme Nachbar
um diese Geschichte zu verstehen müssen
wir weit in die Vergangenheit
zurückgehen nämlich bist du 4 juli
1776 was an diesem Tag geschah
[Musik]
1776 unterzeichneten die 13 Kolonien die
später die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika bilden sollten ihre
Unabhängigkeit vom Vereinigten
Königreich und wisst ihr was Marokko war
das erste Land der Welt das diese
Unabhängigkeit anerkannte 1786
unterzeichneten bei der Nationen dazu
einen Freundschaftsvertrag mit anderen
Worten Rabatt ist so etwas in der
älteste Verbündete Washingtons sie sind
seit mehr als 200 Jahren befreundet
und ich weiß was viele von euch jetzt
denken werden aber war Marokko damals
nicht eine Kolonie nun ja und nein Ende
des 18 Jahrhunderts war Marokko einen
Monarchie Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts über
vielen Frankreich und Spanien das Land
und machten es zu einem Protektorat
[Musik]
im Jahr 1956 wurde Marokko jedoch wieder
unabhängig und die allerlieb dynastik
kehrte an die Macht zurück mit anderen
Worten marokko ist eine Monarchie die
mit dem besten verbündet ist in
Verbündete Vereinigten Staaten und sogar
ein Verbündeter von Israel ist es eine
Demokratie nein natürlich nicht aber es
ist ein stabiler Verbündeter in einer
Region in der Verbündete schwer zu
finden sind wenn man den islamischen
Terrorismus in Nordafrika bekämpfen will
dann ist es eine große Hilfe Marokko an
seiner Seite zu haben das erklärt warum
sich die meisten westlichen Länder
darunter auch die Vereinigten Staaten
weil die Streitigkeiten zwischen Spanien
und Marokko zurückhaltend aber darüber
werden wir später sprechen wer ist also
marokkus größter Feind werdet ihr euch
fragen seine ehemaligen Frankreich und
Spanien nein
[Musik]
Algerien das Russland Nordafrikas
Algerien und Marokko haben eine Menge
gemeinsam beide sind mehrheitlich
muslimische Länder beide sind ehemalige
französische Kolonien beide Länder haben
sich sogar gegenseitig bei der Erlangung
der Unabhängigkeit geholfen doch sobald
es ihnen gelangt das koloniale Joch
abzuwerfen begann die Probleme 1963 als
das unabhängige Algerien als vier Jahre
alt war brach ein Krieg Marokko wegen
territorialer Streitigkeiten aus und die
beiden Länder haben das Kriegsfall bis
heute nicht begraben denk mal darüber
nach Marokko ist eine pro westliche
Monarchie algerien ist eine Republik des
arabischen Sozialismus und was ist
arabischer Sozialismus
Sozialismus ist ein ideologischer
Cocktail der sich in vielen muslimischen
Ländern große beliebter erfreute wir
können an dieser Stelle mit drei
hauptaspekten definieren Säkularismus
Militarismus und der Kult um einen
Herrscher oder Führer im Fall von
Algerien sollten wir nicht von einem
bestimmten Führer sprechen sondern eher
von der sogenannten also der macht dies
ist eine Gruppe von Militär sie alle
politischen und wirtschaftlichen Hebel
des Landes kontrolliert um euch eine
kleine Vorstellung davon zu geben
während Marokko inzwischen
us-militärstützpunkte beheimatet hat
Algerien che guebara empfangen und alle
möglichen Abkommen mit der Sowjetunion
geschlossen und ihr werdet sagen okay
aber abgesehen von den Ideologien
worüber streiten sich diese beiden
Länder nun es geht hauptsächlich um
territoriale Streitigkeiten vor allem um
den Streit um ein bestimmtes Gebiet die
Westsahara
die Rede ist von einer Region im Westen
besser Haare Wüste alle Atlantikküste
hier leben nur etwa 500.000 Menschen
Marokko überhaupt jedoch das ist eine
weitere Region innerhalb seines Landes
sei tatsächlich werden 80% dieses
Gebiets de facto von Marokko
kontrolliert weil wir ihn hingegen
unterstützt die Unabhängigkeit des
Sahara dieser Konflikt liegt bei den
1960er Jahren auf dem Tisch und wenn ihr
euch mehr für dieses Thema interessiert
haben wenn eigenes visuelle Politik
Video indem wir es im Detail behandeln
aber das Wichtigste an der heutigen
Geschichte ist das Marokko oder Algerien
schlecht miteinander auskommen und es
wird immer schlimmer im Jahr 2021 wurden
drei algerische Lastwagen in der
Westernhagen überfallen seitdem befindet
sich die beiden Länder praktisch am
Rande eines Krieges genauer gesagt haben
Algerien und Marokko aber August 2021
ihre diplomatischen Beziehungen
abgebrochen behalte des Datum August bzw
September 2021 im Hinterkopf ist es wird
später noch wichtig werden natürlich
bedeutet das Ende der diplomatischen
Beziehungen auch das Algerien kein Gas
mehr an Marokko verkauft und ich weiß
was er denkt okay mag das ist ja alles
schon und gut aber was hat Spanien mit
dem ganzen zu tun nur die Ruhe genau das
werden wir uns jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
was hat Spanien mit all dem zu tun
seit Jahrzehnten ist Algerien Spaniens
wichtigster Gaslieferant im Gegensatz
dazu gibt es von Russland nach Spanien
überhaupt keine direkten Pipelines
schaut euch mal diese Karte an
auf der einen Seite haben wir die
Pipeline hier seht immer Pipeline sie
wurde in den 1960er Jahren begonnen und
führt durch Marokko sie verfügt über
eine Kapazität von 12 Milliarden
Kubikmetern um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben der Gesamtverbrauch von Erdgas in
Spanien beträgt 34 Milliarden Kubikmeter
diese pipelplant transportiert also 12
Milliarden Kubikmeter und da sie durch
Marokko führt würde Rabatt gerne 7% des
Gases als Bezahlung behalten ab August
2021 hat Algerien jedoch alle
Beziehungen zu Marokko abgebrochen und
so hat Algerien damals den Transit von
Gas durch diese Pipeline eingestellt
damit hat Marokko alle seine Transit
Rechte verloren aber die Spanisch
Versorgung hat das nicht gefährdet
Algerien konnte Spanien immer noch über
eine andere geliefert die mad Gas
diese Pipeline hat eine Kapazität von 10
Milliarden Kubikmetern und verbindet
Spanien direkt mit Algerien mit anderen
Worten 10 Milliarden Kubikmeter plus 12
Milliarden Kubikmeter sind 22 Milliarden
Kubikmeter das sind mehr als 60% des
spanischen Gasbedarfs und ich weiß was
ihr denkt ist Algerien also das Russland
Spaniens also ein Energielieferant von
dem ist vollkommen abhängig ist nun
nicht ganz anders als Deutschland hat
sich Spanien um die Diversifizierung
seiner gastversorgung gekümmert deshalb
gibt es in Spanien anders als in
Deutschland
Anlagen aber darüber werden wir noch
später sprechen und mit welchen Ländern
hat Spanien und Probleme nun mit Marokko
man könnte zwar sagen dass Marokko ein
großer Freund des Wissens ist aber ein
Freund von Spanien ist es ganz sicher
nicht z.B hat Madrid immer die
Unabhängigkeit der bessere Haare
unterstützt doch nicht nur das
Streitigkeiten über Fischerei Zonen
zwischen den beiden Ländern sind an der
Tagesordnung
man könnte sagen hier hat ein Spanien
und Marokko ihre eigenen mikroversion
des falklandkonflikts im Jahr 2002 viel
Marokko nichts besseres ein als die
Insel perihil zu besetzen und was ist
diese kleine Insel Persil nun sie ist
eine unbewohnte Insel ohne echte
strategische Bedeutung eher ein Felsen
Ozean aber spanien hat seine Armee
geschickt und die Marokkaner in einer
schnellen Operation vertrieben
[Musik]
es geht kein einziger Schuss und heute
nennt man das gerade um die Insel den
petersilienkrieg aber welches Interesse
hatte Marokko überhaupt daran in ein
unbewohntes Eiland ein zu marschieren
nun ich glaube nicht dass das überhaupt
jemand weiß wir müssen es nämlich auch
nicht ich habe euch ja bereits gesagt
das ist in dieser Geschichte kaum eine
rationale Logik gibt was jedoch von
größerer Bedeutung ist als die Insel
Perfektion sind diese beiden Städte
schaut sie euch an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ihr hier seht sind Cota und Melia
das sind zwei spanische Städte an der
marokkanischen Küste Marokko betrachtet
sie als Kolonie die eigentlich Teil
seines eigenen Territoriums sein sollten
cuta und Melia sind jedoch keine Kolonie
es handelt sich um zwei Städte die
genauso Spanisch sind die Madrid oder
Servia ihre Einwohner nehmen an Wahlen
teil haben die gleichen Rechte wie die
Bürger auf dem spanischen steuern wie
alle anderen Spanier aber Marokko sieht
das anders und Marokko ärgert die
Spanier wann immer ist eine Gelegenheit
dazu findet erinnert ihr euch noch an
das Video in dem wir euch erzählt haben
die Weißrussland syrische Migranten an
die Grenze zu Polen und Litauen
geschickt hat nun die Pioniere in der
Kunst ist Einsatzes von Migranten als
politische Waffe waren die Marokkaner an
tausende von Migranten stürmen den Zaun
an der Grenze zwischen Marokko und
Spanien aber nicht nur das Marokko droht
auch damit sie runter und Melia
wirtschaftlich zu isolieren trotzdem
nicht alles ist nur schwarz und weiß die
diplomatischen Beziehungen zwischen
Spanien und Marokko sind gelinde gesagt
kompliziert es gibt jedoch wichtige
Nuancen auf die wir hinweisen müssen
erstens erinnert ihr euch noch daran
dass Marokko eine besondere Beziehung zu
den Vereinigten Staaten hat das bedeutet
dass man tritt die Beziehung zu Rabatt
nicht einfach so abbrechen kann und auch
wenn die diplomatischen Beziehungen
verdammt kompliziert sind könnten ihre
Handelsbeziehungen nicht intensiver sein
gibt es wirklich so viel Handel mit
Marokko nun hier ein Beispiel
in die Text ist das größte
Modeunternehmen in Spanien zu dieser
Gruppe gehört auch Sarah nun in die Text
hat 30.000 Arbeitsplätze im
marokkanischen Tanga es gibt noch mehr
solche wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
zwischen beiden Ländern in gewisser
Weise ist Marokko für Spanien das was
Mexiko für die Vereinigten Staaten ist
und ich weiß was ihr euch jetzt alle
fragt was hat das alles eigentlich mit
dem Gas zu tun nun jetzt kommt er
wirklich interessante Teil dieses Videos
ja Plot Twist mit dem niemand gerechnet
hat
der ultimative plot-test
im Gegensatz zu fast allen anderen
europäischen Ländern kommt fast das
gesamte in Spanien verbrauchte Gas von
Schiffen im Juli 2022 waren 72% des
gekauften Gases Tankkarte transportiert
ist Flüssiggas nur 28% kamen aus
Pipeline und was bedeutet das nur das
bedeutet dass die Spanier bis zum
Ukraine kriegt viel mehr für Gas bezahlt
haben als die Deutschen jetzt aber hat
Spanien damit ein viel stärker
diversifiziertes und damit sichereres
Angebot was man einen Blick auf diesen
Graphen
hier seht ihr die wichtigsten
Gaslieferanten Spaniens schaut euch die
algerische Linie an es gibt einen
bestimmten Punkt an dem die Versorgung
zu sinken beginnt was da los war nun
ganz genau September
2021 der Zeitraum kurz nachdem Algerien
die Beziehungen zu Marokko abgebrochen
hat in diesem Moment wollte auch die
Gaszufuhr durch die Magret Europapark
unterbrochen aber das ist eigentlich
kein Problem wir sehen könnt hat Spanien
nicht lange gebraucht um einen anderen
wichtigen Lieferanten zu finden die
Vereinigten Staaten tatsächlich sind die
USA seit 2022 der hauptexperteur von Gas
nach Spanien und an dieser Stelle kommen
wir wieder auf die Nachricht zurück auf
die wir uns am Anfang gezogen haben seht
ihr noch etwas anderes in diesem Grafen
bringen wir ihn wieder auf den
Bildschirm ja ihr seht richtig im Juni
2022 wurde Russland der zweitgrößte
Gaslieferant Spanien ist ist das einen
Grund zur Sorge bedeutet es dass Spanien
ist Algerien durch Russland ersetzen
wird nein natürlich nicht wenn ihr euch
die Grafik ansieht könnt ihr sehen dass
Spanien mehr von Ländern weniger als von
entsprechende Russland abhängig ist
Russland ist hier nur ein Lieferant von
vielen wo liegt also das Problem und das
Problem sind die Opportunitätskosten
[Musik]
in einer Zeit in der halb Europa kein
Gas mehr aus Russland beziehen will
könnte Spanien eine wichtige Rolle
spielen es würde reichen eine
Gaspipeline zu bauen die Spanier mit
Frankreich verbindet und mit dieser
Pipeline könnte man Gas aus den Rest der
Welt und vor allem algerisches Gas das
viel billiger wäre in ganz Europa weiter
verkaufen dieses Angebot könnte auch
Deutschland erreichen das Projekt lag
bis vor kurzem auf dem Tisch und auch
wenn Frankreich jetzt nicht wollte der
Rest Europas war bereit es hatte auch
einen Namen die mit Kat Pipeline der
Name setzt sich zusammen aus MIDI
katalonia eine Pipeline über die
katalonische Region Spaniens in die mit
die Region Frankreichs aber das Projekt
ist heute Geschichte macron war dagegen
und hat sich durchgesetzt stattdessen
könnte es vielleicht eine
unterwasserpipeline geben von der Region
Barcelona bis Marseille aber auch das
ist noch Zukunftsmusik auf jeden Fall
besitzt Spanien das Potential Erdgas in
ganz Europa zu verteilen und zugleich
von Russland unabhängig zu sein wenn
denn einmal die Infrastruktur dafür
steht
[Musik]
also ist dies das Licht am Ende des
Tunnels was unsere Energieversorgung
betrifft und plötzlich erhält unsere
Geschichte einen unerwarteten an
Sanchez bekräftigt seine Unterstützung
für den marokkanischen Vorschlag zur
Sahara und prodemos dürfte ihm vor auf
Trumps Spuren zu wandeln so sieht's aus
in einer 180 Grad Wende hat die
spanische Regierung beschlossen sich
Marokko anzunehmen und zu Algerien auf
Distanz zu gehen und das ausgerechnet in
einem kritischen Moment in dem sich alle
mit Algerien vertragen wollen um das
Ausbleiben von russischen Gaslieferungen
zu kompensieren
[Musik]
natürlich ist Spanien nicht das einzige
Land das anerkennt dass die Sahara
marokkanisch ist die Vereinigten Staaten
haben es bereits 2020 unter der
Präsidentschaft von Donald Trump getan
und jetzt werden manche denken
sicherlich hat Spanien eine sehr
rechtsgerichtete Regierung deswegen sind
sie Trumps Beispiel gefolgt nun nichts
dergleichen die derzeitige spanische
Regierung ist eine Koalition aus
Sozialdemokraten und Linksextremisten
mit anderen Worten es gibt keine
wirtschaftliche Rechtfertigung für
diesen Schritt und auch keine
ideologische nationale Sicherheit und
diese ist auch nicht im Spiel natürlich
ist es in Spanien ist Interesse die
Beziehungen zu Marokko zu normalisieren
aber indem sie ihnen die beste Haare
überlassen haben haben sie ihr größtes
Druckmittel verschenkt und Spanien hat
sich im Sahara Streifen nicht nur auf
die Seite Marokko gestellt seht euch an
Spanien beginnt über die von Algerien
gekappte Patient Erdgas nach Marokko zu
liefern er kennt ihr darin eine Logik
der auch nicht
zu einer Zeit in der ganz Europa bereit
ist Gas aus anderen Ländern als Russland
zu kaufen in Spanien Marokko den Vorgang
auch wenn es dafür teures LNG Gas kaufen
muss das alles hat natürlich
Konsequenzen zum Beispiel sind die
Beziehungen zu Algerien auf dem
Tiefpunkt und das ist nicht nur eine
diplomatische Angelegenheit Spaniens
gasverkäufe an Marokko führen dazu das
Algerien seine Lieferungen drosselt
[Musik]
die euch vorstellen könnt wollen die
Algeria kein Gas an Spanien verkaufen
damit es in den Händen ihres Erzfeindes
Marokko Landes sie reduzieren also den
Gasfluss nach Spanien aber sind die
Algeria wirklich dazu bereit auf das
Geld zu verzichten dass sie mit dem
Verkauf ihres Gases verdient wohl kommen
im Moment gibt es jedoch viele Käufer
Italien unterzeichnet Energieabkommen
mit Algerien um Russland zu umgehen mit
anderen Worten spanien hat eine Chance
verpasst günstiges Erdgas aus Algerien
zu beziehen Italien nutzt sie derweil
voll aus zu dieser Chaos Politik kommt
derzeit doch ein anderes Phänomen hinzu
und zwar hat Spanien derzeit also im
Oktober und November 22 zu viel Gas und
zwar so viel dass sich die
lng-tankstelle vor der Küste stauen
obwohl sie doch eigentlich das Land
beliefern sollten aber die Speicher sind
bis zum randvoll warum sie voll sind
weil man in ganz Europa Gas gespart hat
und verbunden mit dem bislang warmen
Herbst ist die Nachfrage gesucht die
Lieferungen kommt trotzdem an
entsprechend sind auch die Gaspreise im
herbstlich gefallen ein weiterer Grund
Spanien ist Infrastruktur für LG Gas ist
ein europäischen Vergleich gut ausgebaut
aber Infrastruktur zu regativisierung
ist angesichts der aktuellen gasschwämme
immer noch unzureichend vom Engpass in
die Schwämme Spanien weist nicht wohin
mit dem Gas mit dem Gaspreisen geht es
im Großhandel Stall bergab vor den
europäischen küstenwatten mehrere
Dutzend Tanker mit verflüssigten Erdgas
Spanien weiß nicht mehr wohin mit all
den Brennstoff aber jetzt seid ihr
erstmal an der Reihe denkt ihr das ist
möglich ist diese Entscheidungen
rückgängig zu machen könnte Spanien neue
Bedingungen für den Kauf von Gas aus
Algerien aushandeln ist es wirklich
möglich dass Spanien zu europäischen Gas
Drehscheibe wird wie immer sind wir auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
richtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und die
vielleicht auch dabei gelernt habt
Verzehr gibt es bitte ein leichter sind
und vergiss es auch nicht glücklich und
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
testet auch unverbindlich das Angebot
unseres heutigen spons nordpass der für
die visualpolitik eine ganz besondere
Aktion bietet bei Abschluss eines
zweijahres bekommst du einen Monat
kostenlos dazu wenn du den Link dort
passt und kommst Flash wieso alpolitik
aufrufst den du in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video findest natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über Dividende
von euch mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]